for breaking news from Disney XD's
secret programming facility
it's just located as the miles
underground that's all it's a touching
story of a raccoon a tree construction
that's right it's barbels guardians to
the galaxy the new animated series and
we've stole attorney by Road we borrowed
a special preview why does this feel so
right
hey Fozzie
if we're gonna be hanging out together
you definitely need bigger blasters
hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be a breakdown to the new
guardians of the galaxy footage in case
you forgot they're turning it into a TV
series that will premiere later this
summer so here we go for those that
don't know this is Disney XD the same
channel the Air Star Wars rebels
episodes Star Wars rebels season 2 is
premiering June 20th I would expect this
to come some time after that that's what
you know they said you know secret
underground laboratory it's basically
the same proof of the movie doing the
same type of thing you know something
good something bad so this will pick up
after they've already become a team
because it's animated think of it in the
same way you think of Avengers
Earth's Mightiest Heroes and in the
terms of the types of stories that it
can do it's a lot easier for them to do
characters in the animated universe than
it is for them to do it in live-action
like TV or the movies so don't be
surprised if we see like danos you know
other really big villains that we
normally would not see in the movies
James Gunn's kind of picky about the
characters that he puts in his movies
especially you know guardians of the
galaxy too everyone's just like a little
salty that he's not gonna include Nova
in the movie but we could see Nova in
the guardians of the galaxy cartoon
though fun fact the person who is
voicing Drax the destroyer also does the
voice for gorilla grodd on the flash on
the live-action show just like they did
for Star Wars rebels they probably bring
the first episode to comic-con and
screen it there but they will be
screening stuff on TV pretty close to
that so so don't worry if you can't make
it to comic-con for the first episode in
addition to the the main team we're at
least gonna get Korath Nebula yondu and
Cosmo and the really fun thing about
yawn doing Cosmo is that it's James
Arnold Taylor
so obi-wan Kenobi from the Clone Wars is
going to be playing both those
characters Vanessa Marshall who does the
voice for Hera on Star Wars rebels she's
gonna be playing Gamora so that's gonna
be a lot of fun she has that really
smoky voice that I think will be perfect
for earlier this year they also started
a tie-in comic just called Marvel
Universe guardians of the galaxy that
started in February so that's actually
been going on it's a monthly title but
it's based on the stories that they're
doing on the TV show so it ties in more
with the TV show than it will with the
films there's a lot of TV series that
are doing that right now like both the
arrow and the flash have tie-in comics
usually they're a little bit smaller
than normal size comics in there a
little bit cheaper but you can find them
on comiXology so you guys let me know
like what kind of stories do you want to
see them do on the cartoon series and
use Star Wars rebels as a reference
that series is a little bit different
and then it doesn't involve characters
that are from the movies
although the animated characters will
show up in the future Star Wars films
eventually you like it in some capacity
I know we all want to see like a lot of
fan oohs Infinity Gauntlet just telling
a lot of like the in-between time you
know because typically during the movies
you only get one adventure but you get
the idea that because of the time span
they're having all these other
adventures in between movies so that's
really where the TV series picks up the
slack so what I'm hoping is is that
they'll announce an official premiere
date pretty soon especially around Comic
Con once they do I'll start doing more
regular videos for the cartoon be sure
to subscribe to get everything if
there's any guardians of the galaxy to
videos you guys want me to do just leave
your requests in the comments it's been
a little wild but James Gunn is still in
the middle of writing the script right
now the only new information that he's
offered is no Nova no Jason to spartax
there will be a new character joining
the Guardians team but he didn't say who
that was gonna be only that it would not
be another human James Gunn did say that
the cartoon wouldn't be connected to the
film at least not in the way that agents
of shield is connected to the films it
was really funny he was actually
reacting to someone else saying that
they would be connected because the
mantra is everything is connected but I
guess this is evidence that it's not you
guys let me know would you be upset if
the card two didn't crossover with the
film's I think you'd be okay because the
problem with shows like Athens our
shield is that when they say that
they're connected and then they only
give each other like a phone call
technically you know that's that's not
connected usually when they sell big
crossovers like that you expect big
actors to come on the TV show and you
expect the TV actors to go in the movies
so I started to be a little more worried
about when they say everything is
connected so while you guys wait for
that stuff to post you can click here to
learn what's going on with the Winter
Soldier in Captain America's Civil War
and you can click here for my top 5
Suicide Squad stories thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you